the Joe Rogan experience doesn't harm
but imagine if that was really what life
was like you started off as a
single-celled thing and then that died
and the next life you come back as a
multi-celled organism and then that dies
and then you work your way through the
worm world the insect world a spider
world what if we're at the end of a long
process that started not just
biologically started with the the first
single-celled organisms but like that's
a graduation that the life-form has to
go through I think I think that would be
done I am but I think it would be cool
and if people had an idea that that's
what was happening I think people would
be a lot more mindful
you'd be like cuz you will experience
every level along the way it would mean
something to be at the level that we're
at right yeah people wouldn't take life
for granted as much because it's like
man I I have to go through every step of
the way to get to here I'm saying when
you also run into people that seem like
they got a [ __ ] up roll of the dice
from the start
mm-hmm like almost like even almost like
they're starting out life at a deficit
from another life like they owe money on
their past life like they [ __ ] their
past life up so bad they're coming back
in this one they're doing their best but
you should have pay the tickets off
wrong and then there's other people that
believe [ __ ] that's even weirder and all
this shit's weird right cuz here's
what's weird just what we know is true
people have sex they make babies those
babies live just be a certain time and
then they die and they have sex and they
have babies and that we just all keep
doing this but everybody's living like
they're living forever right that's
that's crazy
is it so crazy that you do this same
life over and over and over again until
you get it right is that crazy
I don't think it's crazy it's almost
satisfying because it's like oh I have
another shot at doing it right because
this one wasn't here's what I wanted to
be but doesn't that I think that mind
[ __ ] you if you really knew that that
was true
you'd be so buying [ __ ] you would I
don't know if you'd be able to live in
the moment right yeah because you would
be so concerned and like yeah I got
their lives no I'm not worried about it
well not just that but you would be
thinking like what's the point
it's just I'm just gonna do this forever
and ever and ever
wrecking my cool with that do you think
the human mind wants like a like a kind
of a structure and ending like they want
a like an ending I want to know how this
ends well this is how you have to look
at it this is how you don't have to look
it this way but from this is how I look
yeah that's the way I look at a job we
all we exist in these shifts that we all
agree are necessary like sleep like so
we all have on and off and on and off
and nobody violates that there's no no
one gets to not go off on and off you
could hold off off for a long time and
eventually two days I've been up for 48
hours boom and you go down you might go
down for 12 hours right we all agree
that this is a part of this thing that
we do so I think we take comfort in like
having markers like oh it's lunchtime
oh it's deer time let's watch a show and
then I'm gonna take a shower and go to
bed and you know it gets to you get to
these markers or they they're in your
head and it kind of makes life make
sense like oh you're just looking
forward to the next thing and looking
forward to the next thing but if you
knew for a fact that this life goes on
forever forever and ever and ever it
could go on a million eon so you got to
get it right right if this life doesn't
give a [ __ ] with the 1950s we're like or
what kind of cars people drove in the
70s as life doesn't give a [ __ ] it's
just gonna do the same thing again over
and over and over and over and over
again yeah there's some kind of yeah
maddening kind of that's crazy
what if it's even worse talk to me Joe
what if you start off as a single-celled
organism again right you got to work
your way all the way through like yeah
reincarnation is real but it takes
millions of years
what if reincarnation is real but what
if you like you get to the top of the
game and then BOOM start off as a bug
and you go through the whole Sun go
through the whole thing all over again
until you become you again the exact
same you confronted by the exact same
situations with different outcomes maybe
like a hint like something in the back
your heads like hey man I think we've
done this before I don't do it this time
hey man but that's the one that you like
it's too long
boom yeah but that's what makes it
interesting is to have a recollection of
the previous you know that's that's what
would change and you know iron [ __ ] is
too hard yeah I sometimes I feel like
you do you have something because we
know that like dogs have like serious
instincts men like crazy instincts that
are built-in they all have them
like where's that coming from where are
they getting the information why do they
know to smell piss why do they know that
pee on the spot that another dog did
like I didn't have to teach my dog that
they do it every dog does it it's like
where is that information right what is
happening to that dog that wants to do
that and where is it getting that from I
think it's getting it through its gene
it's genetics getting through ancestors
so there's some sort of a membrane or
programming that the ancestors have left
in the thing it's not a blank slate dogs
are not blank slates I mean they say
everything has you know some kind of
level of programming even plants at the
molecular level they say they have like
kind of like a binary code in there if
you look deep down inside I've read
stuff online and it's like I kind of
believe that it's all part of like some
kind of program of some sort
[Applause]